As old conflicts rumble on, and new threats emerge,
one image, more than any other will be replicated around the globe
In a year that will see the biggest display of democracy in history
what else will the next 12 months bring?
Here are some of the stories set to shape the world ahead
2024 will be the biggest election year in history
More than half of the world’s population live in countries
holding national elections
But there are two elections in particular that could have
huge repercussions worldwide
One is the most powerful democracy in the world
The other is a small, self-governing island
less than 200km off the coast of China
The election in Taiwan in January matters
because the island’s future is so uncertain
According to US intelligence, President Xi Jinping wants his
armed forces to be ready for an invasion by 2027
Taiwan is a geopolitical flashpoint
An invasion by China could lead to war with America
So the stakes are high for whoever wins power
in both Taiwan and America
The strategy they pursue could deter a Chinese invasion—
or hasten it
On the island itself the threat—for some—is already tangible
More than half of Taiwanese citizens do not have confidence
in their government’s ability to defend against an invasion from China
Well of course you have to know
what the wound is to treat it
Some citizens are even taking civil-defence workshops,
including 22-year-old Chen Buo Yen
With regard to the possibility of war,
it’s best to be as prepared as you can be
It would be a lie to say that I am not afraid
but I am prepared
And those concerns will be at the forefront of Taiwanese
voters’ minds when they head to the polls in January
Voters will be faced with a choice between the current ruling party
which emphasises Taiwanese self-rule
and the need to resist Chinese bullying
And two opposition parties, keen to pursue warmer relations
Supporters of the current government claim the opposition
would make it easier for China to ultimately take over Taiwan
And on the other hand,
the opposition camp thinks that
the DPP government is going
to take Taiwan towards a path of
legal independence
And that will be a path to
eventual war with China
The likelihood of war won’t just depend on
what happens in Taiwan’s election, but in America’s too
Would you send the US military into Taiwan
if President Xi were to invade? President Biden says he would
I won’t say, I won’t say
A second Trump presidency would spell unpredictability
and mounting levels of risk
And not just for Taiwan, but for America and the rest of the world
In July, all eyes will be on Paris for the 2024 Olympic games
But while athletes battle it out on the ground,
spectators’ eyes might be drawn to the skies above
At first glance, it might be mistaken for a helicopter
But this is a supersized drone
And it could be the future of public transport
Known as eVTOLs
electric vertical, take-off and landing
They run entirely on batteries
making them a sustainable way to fly
Five years ago eVTOLs were only known to a very small group of people
that were really aviation geeks tinkering on new technologies
Over the last year or so, we’ve seen a lot of public test flights
and next year commercial service is the milestone
If all goes to plan, the Paris Olympics
will mark the start of commercial eVTOL flights
Volocopter, the company running the flights,
is hoping to transport tourists along five different routes
at speeds of up to 110kph
We believe if we can fly in Paris, we can fly anywhere
This is also a start into a new area of mobility
Allowing quiet, safe and sustainable vehicles
to enter the city centres, which other vehicles can’t
The technology is evolving so rapidly
that aviation regulators are struggling to work out how to certify flights
Volocopter has had to roll back on its original plan
of pilotless, self-flying eVTOLs to try to appease the authorities
I think the only way to get certified right now and for the years to come
is by offering a piloted version
It’s not technology that hinders us to go towards autonomy
It is certification and public acceptance
Volocopter is not the only company hoping to take off in 2024
Across the world, other companies are racing to the skies
in a market that could be worth $1trn by 2040
But while much of the industry will be commercial,
some companies will be catering for those who prefer to go private
We’ve got two large wings
you’re getting all your lift from
In 2024, Palo Alto startup Pivotal will be launching an eVTOL
anyone with deep enough pockets, can purchase and pilot themselves
With just one seat, it’s more of a flying motorbike
than a flying taxi
The feeling is pretty hard to describe
to see the world from up there
The company provides a few weeks of training
but you don’t need a pilot’s licence
As long as it’s only flown over rural land and during daylight
The Helix will be one of the most
easy-to-learn-to-fly vehicles ever made
You need to use a single joystick to do
everything the aircraft can do
from takeoff to landing,
to hover, to forward flight
Although, with a price-tag of $190,000, they’re not cheap
There is no denying
that it’s going to be used
principally for recreation to start
but it will grow from there
and it will become a new form of transportation
that we take for granted someday
I’m Tom Standage, editor of The World Ahead
To read about the prospects for the coming year,
and get a head start on more of the trends and themes to watch,
why not take out a subscription to The Economist
which includes full access to The World Ahead 2024?
To get the best offer, click on the link
In 2024 the focus on AI won’t just be on what it can do
but how humans might control it
Some people are worried that if you impose strict rules too early
you stifle the technology
and other people are worried that if you don't move now
then there could be dangerous consequences
So far, much of the discussion around regulation
has been on the most powerful AI,
known as frontier models,
and the risks they could pose to humanity
But there's a danger that decision-makers are looking the wrong way
We should be focusing on the real immediate potential
but also the real immediate risks of this technology
which aren’t about killer robots
they’re about things like bias and discrimination
Many governments are less than transparent about
how they deploy AI in decision-making
In London, the charity the Public Law Project has been trying
to uncover how the British government is using algorithms
So we can see 28 tools
that are currently being used by the Home Office
One of their projects examines the British government’s use of
machine learning, a form of AI, in its investigation of welfare fraud
People who were applying for welfare support,
all of the same nationality background,
they were having their benefits suspended
for a really long period of time
We were really concerned that some of these systems
might be operating in a way that’s discriminatory
There is precedent for this
In 2021, an AI welfare scandal
brought down the Dutch government
The tax service here in the Netherlands
was wrongfully accusing tens of thousands of families
that they were frauding with child benefits
And Australia's “Robodebt” scandal
led to at least two suicides
Driven to despair by a soulless, automated debt collector
and a government who called them welfare cheats
There has been some movement
in an attempt to mitigate near-term risks
The EU is expected to bring in its AI Act in 2024
There will also be two AI safety summits
One in South Korea and one in Paris
But if they are anything like the first safety summit
at Bletchley Park in 2023
their focus will be mostly on frontier models and existential risk
I think talking up these existential, theoretical future risks
is really just a way of hyping the technology overall
Elon Musk would like to sell you a
self-driving car that uses AI to drive itself
but he also says that AI is really, really dangerous
If we are not careful with creating artificial general intelligence
we could have potentially a catastrophic outcome
Some people go as far as to say that
this is actually a deliberate sort of
decoy trying to distract attention from the
real existing harms of AI systems
And it’s also a way of drawing attention
for the people who work in the field
to just how powerful and wonderful they are
They’re really saying
“I made this thing that could destroy the world
Aren’t I clever?”
In 2024 one of the world’s
overlooked greenhouse-gas emitters
will finally be in the spotlight
Until now, governments’ focus
has been on cleaning up the most visible polluters
like energy and transport
But in the coming year, attention
will turn towards industry
and the production of materials central to modern everyday life
Industry is often out of sight
unlike the cars we drive or the electricity that powers our homes
But, in fact, almost everything
that we need in our lives is made by industry
Factories and other industrial facilities
belch out vast amounts of greenhouse gases
Nearly 29% of all emissions
That’s the same amount as electricity generation
and almost double transport
A big part of the problem
is that some industrial processes
need high temperatures,
which at the moment rely on fossil fuels,
like coal and natural gas
That's been a real challenge
But that’s also turning into a real opportunity
for some innovators
Coolbrook is a Finnish startup
developing technology it thinks can bring the world
one step closer to green industry
Their rotodynamic heater
generates high temperatures using electricity
This really is the heart and soul of the installation
The gas goes around the doughnut multiple times
and then exits from the other side
Which means with the use of renewable electricity,
it can power industry with entirely sustainable energy
What we want to do
is that we replace majority of fossil fuels in the industry,
and that is very much doable
After decades of development,
2024 is the year this technology will start being shipped to factories
It’s absolutely exciting times
The last ten years have been already
the time of intensive development,
and last two to three years
have really been the game-changer for us
What we have now seen is that the heavy industry
is really starting to move
Industry might be more willing to decarbonise
because of incoming regulation
In 2023, the European Union
introduced a carbon tax on imports
We’ll see how it actually plays out in 2024
We’re likely to see other big economies
the United States, the UK and Australia
come up with their own versions of a carbon tax
And this kind of regulation has spurred
the creation of other decarbonising technologies
A few startups have come up with new ways
of containing renewable energy
in sometimes what are called “rocks in a box”,
sort of small packages
that get very hot, retain the heat
and can release it on demand when a factory needs it
But industry can sometimes drag its feet
and questions remain about whether it can change fast enough
One of the obstacles to decarbonising heavy industry
is that the processes are very complicated
It can be expensive and involve investment
in new capital equipment which industry does not want to do
Factory bosses don’t like to shut down their factories
and replace the kit that they use
because of the dreams of environmentalism
It’s a bit like changing the wheels on a bus
while the bus is moving at full speed,
but that’s kind of what we have to do
In 2024, the American-led
world order is going to be challenged again
as a bloc of non-Western nations gets bigger
The BRICS, made up of Brazil,
Russia,
India,
China
and South Africa will add five new members
Individually, the BRICS are some of the most exciting
and biggest economies on the planet
China is the world’s second-biggest economy
India is growing rapidly
In 2024, the club of five will be joined by Egypt,
Ethiopia, Iran, Saudi Arabia and the United Arab Emirates
Argentina was also slated to join,
but that now looks unlikely
under its new president, Javier Milei
On paper, BRICS+ seems a formidable outfit
Together, its members account for
nearly half of the world’s population
and their share of GDP
is around 20% more than the G7,
a group of rich democracies allied to America
But in reality,
their power will depend on how well they get on
They don’t seem to have that much in common
They are very, very different economies
India is on a huge kick about green minerals
China seems to be driving its economy towards consumption
rather than investment
What’s more,
there have been recent skirmishes
between China’s and India’s armies
across their shared border
There’s also a chance
that we’ll have found out that the BRICS mean
very little other than a club
for people to discuss things
But what’s really interesting about all these countries
that are joining next year
is that they’re the countries that have had
some of the most strained relations
with the West and its financial order
This global financial system was created
in the ashes of the second world war
At Bretton Woods, 44 nations
gathered to establish a new
international monetary and financial order
with America at the helm
What’s significant about the expansion of BRICS
is that it challenges this American-led world order
The most important thing about the BRICS
has always been that America isn’t invited
and there are ways in which the BRICS are using
that American-dominated financial system
and trying to twist it to their own advantage
The BRICS have created their own alternative
to the World Bank
and their own currency swap lines
in which countries agree
to swap different currencies,
countering the influence of the IMF
and its currency of choice,
the dollar
And it’s not just
America’s global economic influence
that is being challenged by the rise
of middle powers
The world is changing and America’s influence is declining
America is also a security power,
and its military is far superior
to any other countries in the world
But increasingly, there are several smaller,
rich countries that are playing the role
of the world’s negotiator
In the war in Ukraine, much of the
mediation has been done by Turkey
And in the war in Gaza,
by Qatar
America’s power is unlikely
to be eclipsed anytime soon
Its network of allies
is still much bigger than China’s
But in 2024,
expect the world to become more multipolar
as middle powers flex their muscles
Thanks for watching
To read more of our coverage of the coming year,
click the link
and don’t forget to subscribe